in 2008 the Visceral Games title
deadspace introduced us to Isaac Clark a
lowly engineer forced to fight his way
off at zombie-infested station it was an
instant hit dead space racked up over 2
million sales nabbed a handful of awards
and spawned sequels in 2011 and 2013 and
then nothing here's why we never got to
play dead space 4 dead space 3 didn't
sell in an interview with CVT former
Electronic Arts President Frank Gibeau
said ultimately you need to get audience
sizes of around 5 million to really
continue to invest in an IP like dead
space sadly dead space 3 didn't sell
anywhere close to 5 million copies in
its first week of release Dead Space 2
shipped nearly 2 million copies by
contrast dead space 3 moved only six
hundred and five thousand units that was
well below EAS initial estimates and the
games failure contributed to EAS
year-over-year revenue loss of over a
hundred and fifty million in 2013 likely
making it difficult to justify a sequel
critics were critical according to the
review aggregator Metacritic the first
two dead space games received average
reviews scores of 89 and 90 percent
respectively for their Xbox 360 version
dead space 3 on the other hand only
score 278 while this is still slightly
above average for video games it was a
disappointment for the franchise with
critics knockin the titles move away
from survival horror for its more
generic action mediocre reviews in tepid
word-of-mouth from players may help
explain why sales died an unspeakably
brutal death
survival-horror is changing
despite some innovative features the
first two dead space games are very much
traditional survival horror titles most
a dead space extension comes from
navigating the game's harsh and violent
environments with limited resources
awesome strategically placed gore and a
smattering of haunted house style jump
scares round everything out but a lot
has changed since the first dead space
came out in 2014 a playable trailer
called PC took the gaming world by storm
with its haunting surreal imagery and
shifting geography the game PG promoted
a Silent Hill reboot by hideo kojima an
acclaimed film director Guillermo del
Toro never materialized but the trailer
was enough to galvanize the survival
horror genre with games moving towards
psychological horror dead spaces action
formula was beginning to look well David
the Stars has moved on Glenn Schofield
who created dead space left visceral and
Electronic Arts in 2009 to form its own
company sledgehammer games write Bagwell
lead gameplay designer on dead space and
creative director on dead space to join
Zynga in 2011 where he led the design
team on farmville 2 and steep losses
visceral vice president and general
manager and the lead executive on all of
the dead space game part of the company
in 2015 in other words the people who
made the franchise great in the first
place have left Star Wars inspired by
dead space's popularity Electronic Arts
had dice handed visceral the reins for
the shoot-'em-up battlefield hardline
and from there
visceral main office went straight to
work on an ambitious and mysterious Star
Wars title overseen by uncharted Amy
Hennig that's exciting news for fans of
both Star Wars and visceral but it
doesn't leave much time for dead space
visceral is booked for the next few
years and if there's going to be more
dead space it'll have to wait until
visceral returns from its trip to a
galaxy far far away
or farther away than their usual one
it's a rarity losers
Han Solo's a [ __ ] it lost its way the
first two dead space games our conscious
throw backs the movies like alien with
the schlubby Isaac forced to fight his
way alone through invested combined
spaces the dead space 3 is different and
a conscious attempt to reach a wider
audience Electronic Arts added co-op
multiplayer to the main campaign and a
stereotypically grizzled soldier buddy
named John carbon the tight
claustrophobic levels are replaced by
snow fields and wide open space allowing
a suddenly more nimble Isaac to simply
dodge out of the way a danger and duck
effortlessly behind protected cover in
other words the series loss what made it
special getting it back will be no easy
feat a reboot makes more sense
visceral Star Wars game is still a
number of years away and that doesn't
count extra time that the studio will
spend on post-launch downloadable
content and a potential sequel by that
point it will have been well over a half
decade since the last dead space game
hit confluence even with tacked on
cliffhanger ending from the dlc it might
make more sense for the company to
reboot the franchise with a new
direction and new characters rather than
continue with something that was no
longer working it could be the Dead
Space is officially dead but if the
series is anything like its Necromorph
monsters it will come back to life
before long on second thought maybe it
should thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
you